has been feeling a little bit low on  self-esteem today we are waiting for him  to arrive  and this is one of the first times we've  ever seen magnus be the first to arrive  ooh is it a mental game from eric how  dare you disrespect  uh looks like magnus choosing some music  yeah looking through the playlists yeah  trying to choose his get pumped mix do  you know i nearly uh got arrested for  stealing cake earlier bit of a random  fact tell us all about it just while we  wait for the game so i sent ivanka a  picture of a lovely cake yeah cake i  like my cake quite clearly um but i went  down the supermarket and it's one of  those ones where you scanned your things  yeah and i forgot to scan my cake i went  to walk out all the alarms went off oh  no no idea was going i thought i'd just  go through it securely got me there like  yeah and i'm like